one piece is one of the bestselling
manga series of all time and arguably
one of the most popular pop culture
properties in the whole world but how
did this pirate manga become king of the
stories given the enormous success of
both one piece and Dragon Ball it makes
sense that auro Oda was inspired in part
by what Akira Toriyama had done with his
series the folks at the one piece
podcast translated an interview between
Oda and Naruto writer Masashi Kishimoto
in which the former called Tori a huge
influence I'd have to say that Toriyama
Sensei has been a huge influence of
course there's Dragon Ball but I really
loved Dr slump as well although the
rules of each Universe are different the
core elements of one piece and the Rogue
cast of characters at its Center have a
lot in common with the mly crew that
Goku assembles over the course of Dragon
Ball in a conversation with Toriyama Oda
even acknowledged that he had fallen in
love with Dragon Ball the second he
stumbled across it Oda also said that
there were specific things about the art
style in the series that inspired him
including the way that Toriyama Drew
muscles and hands although we could
forgive a chiro Oda for deciding to rest
on his Laurels after creating one of the
most profitable stories in history
that's not the path he chose instead Oda
continues to work a very intense
schedule and does a lot of the drawing
for One Piece himself this process means
that Oda is often working exceedingly
long days and suggests that he demands a
lot of himself in order to make sure
that the stories in one piece are told
the way he wants them to be Oda
reportedly wakes up at 5:00 a.m. and
continues working on through 2: a.m. the
next day and rarely takes a day off even
on weekends one piece became an enormous
success in part because of oda's
attention to detail and it seems even
now that it's world famous Oda still
wants to make sure his story is told
with as much precision and care as
possible Oda initially thought that he
would be able to end the story of One
Piece after 5 years according to a
translated quote found on an amino anime
blog although Oda knows how now the
series will end he realized it would
take him longer to get there than he had
initially suspected he also acknowledged
that he liked the story too much to wrap
it up that quickly and ultimately
decided to keep it going much longer
than originally planned in 2019 Otis
said that he predicts one piece would
end within the next 5 years according to
anime News Network the series is on its
way toward a definitive conclusion and
at this point that ending is still the
one that Oda envisioned when he
initially planned to end the series
after 5 years although the series will
have run for more than 25 years by the
time it actually ends Oda is clearly
committed to seeing his vision for the
manga's ending
realized on top of the movies video
games and the anime one piece finally
got a liveaction adaptation in 2023
courtesy of Netflix the liveaction one
piece admittedly caters to American fans
of the series but it also works as a
part of Netflix's broader push to reach
a larger International audience one
piece is a global property and with Oda
serving as an executive producer on the
series fans are around the world can be
comfortable that this new adaptation
will continue to work as yet another
part of the franchise plus with a second
season officially greenlet fans have
more of the liveaction adventure to look
forward to that went pretty
well don't you think much like how my
hero was a pilot of sorts for my hero
Academia romance Dawn by aho Oda was a
prototype for the one piece Story the
first version of romance Dawn was a
50-page oneshot published in the Shonen
Jump 1996 special on August 4th the
second version was only 45 pages long
and released in the 41st issue of weekly
shown and jump the following month both
versions share similar elements that are
present in the finalized version of the
manga while differing in many ways for
example Monkey D Luffy is more concerned
about going on fun adventures than
becoming King of the Pirates the two
female leads from the respective
versions of romance Dawn silk in the
first version and an in the second
version are clear prototypes of Nami the
devil fruits are said to come from a
mystical tree in the second version of
romance Dawn while their origin is still
a mystery in one piece red-haired Shanks
sacrifices his left arm to save Luffy
and gives Luffy his straw hat in the
first version of the story in the second
version Luffy is inspired by his pirate
grandfather who shares the same
characteristics as Luffy's grandfather
Monkey D GARP in one Piece romance Dawn
has been adapted in various ways the
first version was adapted as an anime
Special called one Piece romance Dawn
Story the second version became episode
907 of the TV anime series while Monkey
D Luffy went through minimal changes
through the various prototypes of One
Piece the remaining members of the straw
hat Pirates went through various changes
in their initial development before
becoming the Pirates they are today the
characters of silk and Anne from romance
Dawn paved the way for Nami in the
finalized story however according to the
fourth Data Book one piece green secret
pieces Nami originally had a giant
battle axe as her signature weapon
instead of a bow and was going to be a
cyborg the adorable Tony Tony Chopper
was originally a more realistic reindeer
who walked on two legs and smoked in an
interview with Shonen jump a Cho Oda
said the reason why he changed Chopper's
original appearance is it Blended too
much with the other characters so he
made Chopper more distinct cute and
small the former pirate Hunter roronoa
Zoro was envisioned as The Bodyguard for
buggy the star clown the chain smoking
cook Sanji was going to be named Naruto
however with the Naruto manga about to
start serialization Odo wisely changed
the name to avoid any confusion between
the two characters the fantasy world of
One Piece might be a work of fiction but
many of the series outlandish characters
are inspired by real life pirates from
the 17th century Goldie Roger arguably
the most important character in one
piece shares inspiration with two real
life pirates the first is the French
pirate Olivier lavasier who upon his
hanging tossed a cryptogram from the
scaffolding into the crowd and told them
if they could figure out the message his
treasure would be theirs leasure's
treasure was never found similarly
Goldie Roger tells Pirates everywhere to
go look for his treasure the one piece
before he's executed by the world
government the second source of
inspiration for Goldie Roger is Henry
ever an English pirate who led possibly
the most profitable pirate rate of all
time in 1695 after capturing a treasure
estimated at around $95 million in
today's currency Evy became known as the
arch pirate for his tremendous wealth
there are other examples of real life
pirate references in one piece such as
the real Blackbeard Edward Teach and
spiring Marshall D leader of the
Blackbeard Pirates there's also the
Welsh pirate Bartholomew Roberts serving
as inspiration for Bartholomew Kuma the
legend of AA for iron Ma alvida and the
Irish pirate Anne Bonnie for Captain
jewelry Bonnie Easter eggs in anime are
pretty common and one piece is no
exception to the rule one of the most
prominent and commonly deployed Easter
eggs of a Cho Oda is pandam man an
anthropomorphic Panda wrestler he drew
for a Kuman character creation contest
when he was a teenager as he explained
in volume seven of the One Piece manga
as a joke character pandaan has been
featured in various materials such as
anime manga movies and video games his
lore even unfolds in various backgrounds
as his love interest Panda woman his
angry unpaid creditors the Tomato gang
and his great rival the unforgivable
mask have all made cameos in Oda
projects even though one piece gets away
with a lot more than your average kids
cartoon in the US it still has a younger
skewing audience in Japan therefore the
anime tends to water down the manga's
most graphic moments case in point
characters who give the middle finger in
the manga do not do so in the anime
there are various examples of characters
flipping the bird to others in the manga
so much so that it became a running gag
the one character most associated with
this offensive gesture is troger D water
law when law meets eustus kid at the
human auctioning house he gives him the
middle finger in the anime La simply
shoots kid a smug grin when Don kyot
doflamingo defeats la in the dress Rosa
Arc of the manga law gives him the
middle finger in Defiance the anime
version dulls the edge of this
rebellious Moment by having law verbally
mock doflamingo instead there is no
question that the works of Dragon Ball
and its ilk played a huge role in the
development of one piece but there's one
obscure series that doesn't get enough
credit for inspiring airo Oda as he
stated in numerous interviews Oda became
fascinated with the world of pirates
thanks to a little 1974 cartoon called
Vicki the Viking the show which aired in
Austria Germany and Japan follows a boy
named Vicki who is the son of halvar
chief of the Viking Village of flake
despite being feeble shy and terrified
of wolves Vicki manages to get himself
and his fellow Vikings out of the
toughest situations thanks to his sharp
imagination interestingly enough one
piece isn't the only anime inspired by
Vicki the Viking Makoto yukimura the
writer and illustrator of Vinland Saga
has also cited Vicki the Viking as a
source of inspiration and even drew some
of the main characters from the kids
show as cameos in his manga the one
piece TV anime series from toi animation
has been on the air since 1999 during
that time the show has undergone various
changes in its animation style the
recent adaptation of the wano country
story AR for example has experienced
some significant changes in the new
Show's art style of course change isn't
always a bad thing episode 1015 of One
Piece was praised as one of the most
visually stunning episodes in the series
history however not everyone is on board
with the recent stylistic changes to the
show a few fans have harassed animator
Henry thurow online believing him to be
the cause of the show's controversial
use of power auras that recall fight
scenes from Dragon Ball Z to his credit
thoro took it in stride and poked fun at
the thought of any single animator
having so much creative control over a
mega franchise like one piece there have
also been one piece fans who have
apologized for the harassment thurow has
received and offered their support on
the one piece podcast thoro clarified
the anime's use of aura stating that the
decision of when to use it and by how
much is decided by the individual
episode
directors thanks to the work of
Funimation now known as Crunchyroll the
one piece anime series has experienced a
Resurgence in popularity in North
America the series is widely available
in its original form subbed and dubbed
on various streaming Platforms in
digital stores and home media releases
films like one piece Stampede have been
rolled out at North American theaters to
Commercial Success with one Piece Film
read making its us debut on November 4th
of 2022 North American One Piece fans
have it good that wasn't always the case
however as the defunct four kids
entertainment originally owned the
English rights to the one piece anime
and subjected it to countless
questionable changes like most four kids
dubs of its era one piece was heavily
censored to ridiculous degrees the four
kids dubs were Americanized like crazy
and had most of its original music
replaced by an interchangeable track
worst of all some episodes of One Piece
were skipped or merged into a singular
episode needless to say fans were not
happy with these changes the lasting
Legacy of the four kids dub of One Piece
however is its American intro that tells
the story of the straw hat Pirates
through a reasonably corny rap song
oddly enough four kids also produced an
English cover of we are the first one
piece anime opening song but decided
against using it while hardly anyone
Mourns the loss of four kids and their
rights to one piece the fandom has
embraced the four kids one piece intro
music after all how many other classic
anime series can say they've got a rap
theme song and who can hate a line like
yo ho ho he took a bite of gumgum Sean
FreshCo Conrad The Man Behind the r
explained how the theme song came to be
he even updated the rap for the crew
members that don't get to appear in the
four kids dub who says Monkey D Luffy
doesn't have class while everyone's
favorite straw hat wearing hero hasn't
become king of the Pirates just yet he
has set an unexpected milestone in the
real world he became the first anime
character to Grace the cover of shisha
men's non-no fashion magazine in 9 this
is an amazing feat considering the
publication's 24-year history at the
time it also marked the first time a Oda
had drawn a cover image for a non- Monga
magazine various aspects of One Piece
have been influenced by historical
figures and real life events when
designing the three significant Marine
Admirals from the series Hiro Oda turned
to three late but great Japanese actors
as a source of inspiration for their
appearances Kuan is based on the late
Japanese actor yusaku matsuda who
starred in films like the Beast to die
detective story and Black Rain matsuda's
status as an actor is so legendary that
he also serves as inspiration for
kenshiro from Fist of the North Star and
Spike Spiegel from Cowboy bbop borolo is
based on the late Japanese actor Kun
Tanaka who appeared in films like the
bad sleep well sanjuro and battles
without honor and Humanity finally
sakazuki is based on the late Japanese
actor buun
sugua as one piece is hardly above
promoting product s now and again a
series of One Piece noodle commercials
reimagined the cast as modern-day high
schoolers the advertising campaign was
called Hungry days and it was for the
Japanese food company Nissan foods to
advertise their lineup of instant
noodles the modern-day designs of the
straw hat Pirates were drawn by isaku
kubui Carolyn Tuesday and animated by
shaft Animation Studio in the ad
campaign that ran from May 2019 to
February 2020 each commercial focused on
a crew member that evoked emotional
moments from the series related to that
crew member only reinterpreted to fit
the present day High School theme the
first commercial head roronoa Zoro
swearing to get stronger after losing a
Kendo match to mihawk the second has
Nami being overwhelmed by her high
school studies and evening work at the
arlong pirates restaurant the third
commercial has nefer tari Viv recalling
precious memories of her high school
friends the straw hat crew as she
transfers to a new school the fourth is
an allout brawl between the white team
Whitebeard Pirates and Red Team Marines
in an event involving monkey D Luffy and
his brother Port Goos D Ace one of the
great things about the one piece series
is the communication between fans and
series Creator aho Oda through the
question and answer column in the manga
Oda often answers fans lingering
questions about the world of One Piece
no matter how ridiculous the questions
may be for volume 56 of the question and
answer column there was one fan who had
a more serious question if one piece was
set in the real world which countries
would the nine straw hats come from od's
response well I'll just put what fits
with the character's image here's what
Oda put down Luffy Brazil zuro Japan
Nami Sweden Usopp Africa Sanji France
chomer Canada Robin Russia Frankie USA
Brook Austria obviously Africa is a
continent and not a country whether or
not Oda has an extremely limited
knowledge of global geography or simply
didn't think hard enough about this
particular fan question is
unknown considering the love and
admiration a Cho Oda and Akira t orama
have for one another it was inevitable
that the two manga creators would work
together on a crossover involving their
popular series and keeping true to their
wacky sense of humor the highly
anticipated one piece and Dragon Ball
crossover was anything but normal cross
Epoch takes the cast of One Piece and
Dragon Ball and puts them in a far out
story where Mr Satan invites everyone to
a little tea party after using the
Dragon Balls to wish to be king in the
end the Dragon Ball and one piece Crews
all make it on time and have fun some of
the characters appearances and
occupations are changed to better mirror
one another Bulma becomes a thief to
match Nami Piccolo Masters sword
fighting to reflect roronoazoro this
isn't the only time one piece and Dragon
Ball have crossed over with each other
as they often appear together in various
Shonen Jump related games like battle
Stadium do or the ill- fated jump Force
according to series Creator AO Oda one
piece is entering its final story arc
meaning the series quarter Century
Journey will soon come to an end there's
no telling where this ship will sail for
its final destination but there's one
thing that everyone can be certain of
before the series is complete at least
one character in one piece will wear an
eye patch confused in the over 1,000
chapters of One Piece there has not been
a single pirate with an eye patch the
same is true for the anime TV series and
movies why according to Oda in the one
piece 10th Treasures special collector's
book he said he wanted to avoid the
stereotypical pirate look Oda is not
against the idea of drawing a pirate
with an eye patch he's just more
interested in the journey that gets them
there he wrote I thought if there's an
image in everyone's head about what a
pirate is then I thought I would write
and draw about the process of the boy
getting there but it's not like I
dislike eye patches so in the final
scenes of One Piece there is one pirate
who appears with an eye patch fans have
speculated that the fabled eye patch
wearing pirate character could be Monkey
D Luffy as the story of One Piece has
been his journey from a young dreamer to
King of the
Pirates h